very nice
[Music]
confiscation are you proposing taking
away their guns and how would this work
i am we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines and you
shouldn't be able to exploit
loopholes and evade criminal background
checks by buying
online or at a gun show to gun owners
out there who
say well a binding administration means
they're going to come for my guns
bingo if i'm elected and or i'm coming
for you
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
[Music]
is
[Music]
see the thing is because we don't want
to buy coke products anymore we got rid
of the torpor
chico and i think we have san pellegrino
in here it
tastes like tastes like wet pennies oh
no plenty of people here buy coke
disgusting yes uh we have a lot to get
to
we had to change the entire map really
today yeah because i don't know if you
know this but minneapolis
is on fire again not in the nba it's jam
sense
girl yeah so we have a lot to get to
today gerald a is here how are you
well how are you i'm terrible uh
quarterback garrett how are you
i'm doing great well except for you know
the riots yeah except for the riots
uh and then we have landau dave on the
twitter atlanta dave are you doing a
show this weekend
ahoy i am i'm going to be in florida
thursday through
uh saturday port charlotte vassani
good food don't wear don't wear your
mask on they kick they kick your ass
around those parts for doing
stuff like that around the oldest people
uh in the country are actually in where
i'm performing and wonderful not as many
of them died because cuomo doesn't run
the show
oh yeah that's pretty nice that's good
news that's the amazing thing too when
you take florida and i get some people
say oh transmission rates it's right in
the middle of the pack
but the fact is like the at the median
age is is almost biden
yeah oh yeah well he's got to start his
sets at four o'clock do you know to
finish up
time so the come on let's wrap it up i
think the early show is six
yeah dinner starts at three
yeah it's the only comedy club where
they offer uh several meal choices they
offer uh standard meal
vegan pescetarian and uh those for those
who can't choose with just a liquid diet
yes they blend it yeah exactly blend the
burger
just instead of getting pelted with
vegetables getting pelted with to go
ninja cups
they all fall short though that's why
oats fossilized so look we have a lot to
get we're gonna be talking about
minneapolis there uh
there's some updates going on as we are
live right now we can go to cnn well
right now it's a giardiance commercial i
don't know what that is but i assume
someone's in pain
in moderate to severe plaque-like pain
and needs it
jeez um so but we will uh
five updates come in we'll be uh we'll
be uh following it but first
look i don't know how much further we
have to go for people to declare this
orwellian like we've talked
about we had our uh videos removed as it
related to anything
election related covid which we can so
let's not repeat what we said about
it because we would never say that the
cdc numbers have you know different
mortality rates for young people and old
people
oh never and compare it to the flu i
would never encourage you to go directly
to the cdc website and read their own
numbers
no no we wouldn't do that but now we're
at the point where youtube deleted a
video
of a round table with governor desantis
and he had with um
medical professionals from harvard
oxford and stanford but
according to youtube they don't follow
the science um
yeah harvard stanford and oxford the
people who got james de moray removed
uh without question they're the ones who
are the authorities on science so
um they remove them for covid19
misinformation let me give you uh a
couple of things really quickly so
the guy in question was dr martin
kulduroff of harvard
and what youtube claimed and there's an
article from nbc that it was coveted
misinformation
okay two uh specific instances in the
video
one is where he was talking about covid
and comparing it
to the flu for children in the mortality
rates
not us this is why it was removed
because he said it's he said it's
significantly less lethal than the flu
for children okay so that was a reason
it was removed
and then there was another point in the
video which youtube said was removed and
nbc corroborated this
because then he was asked about the
efficacy of masks
specifically in schools and whether
children should wear masks right
and he said that he didn't think so now
you can't find this anywhere on youtube
so we have tried to obviously as a
public service make this
available to you this is governor ron
desantis
and dr martin kuldura kuldorf
i'm trying my best uh from harvard this
is however we've managed to hopefully
make this
uh youtube friendly so now you know
while anybody can be infected there's a
more than a thousand-fold difference
in mortality risk between the oldest and
the youngest
so for all people have to be very
careful because this
is more dangerous than the annual
influenza but for children
here on youtube it's important i say
it is more deadly than any
pandemic for kids including spanish flu
bubonic plague ricketts
and even aids and herpes is for
life so it's good that we lock them up
uh dr gupta mentioned about you know not
putting mass on kids that's not
effective not necessary
uh martin calder do you agree in school
there's no
no need for them to be wearing face
masks i think children should be wearing
triple masks
and breathing through snorkel that they
make
from scented candle
so ah there you have it it's youtube
friendly there you go
yeah it looks like brown dark brown at
what point do you
say hey look look we are past the point
now where doctors
medical professionals are not allowed to
speak
on current data available that is being
removed from the public town square
yeah absolutely i mean these are our
officials talking to us and whether you
agree with these medical experts or not
they're medical experts they're experts
in their field i mean i'm not sure what
else they need to do to be considered
knowledgeable
on this and then one of the different
first name doctor last name fauci
i know well exactly they didn't get it
from the university of phoenix online no
offense i'm just saying maybe not the
same exactly they've actually trained
patient within the last 40 years you
insult my degree one more time i'm gonna
come over there
i played for the basketball team he's
going to rise from his vpn
yeah right well look look i i think it's
just crazy though that we have people
like this speaking out there and they
basically brought up a point they said
and i'm not going to say what the
guidelines say i'm just saying
that the cdc guidelines on masking kids
is different than who's
that's it yeah they were talking about
the differences the who
and the cdc have differing guidelines
right now i'm not saying that they
completely say one way the other
i'm just saying they have different
guidelines and it's okay to talk about
why and we'll have that available at
ladder with crowder.com um
that being said if you go and check the
link is in the description if you go and
read it
you'll probably be tracked and that
being said just because they advertise
your college during mori doesn't mean
you're garbage
maury still by the way uh dave i don't
know i hope not are the father yeah i am
oh
no he always is oh every let him know on
the show uh and now let's
get to uh what's going on the rest of
the country uh we'll get to minneapolis
in a second which of course is trending
everywhere right now but uh on saturday
over the weekend
uh portland of course not to be outdone
and then it was immediately outdone
they burned down a federal ice facility
yet again want all the ice melts
ah get it
[Music]
[Applause]
and there's more video than you can
watch in a lifetime riders chanting
every city every town burn this precinct
to the ground at least they're better
than heihei ho ho
you know um they also obscure the
security cameras with a traffic cone had
graffiti that read
dhs murders so i don't know uh i guess
you know at some point there will be uh
there will be uh some sort of an article
about them being
insurrectionist i don't know i mean it
seems to me like when you say hey are
you an insurrectionist and the answer is
yes that qualifies if you've
yeah no yeah you know i mean i don't
know i just feel like you know
250 000 people in the capital on january
6th then you had a couple hundred people
who were waved in by the cops and it got
unruly and of course not condoning what
happened there got out of hand
but then from the get-go they're like
hey are you here to peacefully protest
oh no no so we're here for the
insurrection
right this way
what's their particular beef with the
dhs i don't know
i don't think they know i'm curious i
know they hate ice because they believe
in hey i don't know if this is legal as
a matter of fact i'm quite sure it isn't
but i've thought about starting a
gofundme which of course i'd be banned
but i don't know maybe i'll just set up
an account where you can send some
bitcoin
unmarked bills since we're letting which
i guess all bitcoin is unmarked
they're not bills they're coins what am
i talking about the point is i want
all conservative canadians to illegally
migrate to the state of michigan
and i would love to buy homes and create
a com and just just this
just the state of michigan should become
conservative canada
south and what can they do what's
whitmer going to do so everyone right
there who doesn't want to be locked down
for days on end and be arrested for
walking your dog
just go to michigan cross over the
border there's nothing they can do
and of course the housing market is
awful you can get homes for like 11
bucks
depending where you're at depending
where you are hockey back in hockey town
friend
let's do it don't be alarmed by the
giant black fist in in detroit that's
joe lewis it seems more
intimidating than it is but all are
welcome
well and like a nod to communism that's
also just fine
i don't really think that's what it is
no it's just joe lewis it's just the
boxer no
it is joe lewis it has nothing to do
with comments there's there used to be a
sickle there
racist or did not used to be a signal
absolutely there's also the spirit of
detroit who's sitting crisscross
applesauce
that's true all right i can't say the
other way because that's offensive
uh minneapolis this is trending right
now are they they're not talking about
well they're probably not talking about
on cnn because um
some new news has emerged no
so probably what you initially heard was
police again
shoot an unarmed black man with no
reason and look we don't have all of the
information right now
but i can tell you that that's some
[ __ ] so that's enough
to start with okay the idea that was
just an unarmed black man
who was sitting there traffic stop like
hey your tail lights out
and he uh you know unloaded the clip
that's not what happened however
uh duante wright if i have this name
hopefully cor dante duante dante wright
was shot by police during a traffic stop
in minneapolis
uh and uh and immediately of course
protests started to break out here's a
clip showing some of the protests and
also showing the mom
of dante asking people not to do
exactly how they be
but i need you guys to see all the
violence if it keeps going it's only
going to be about the violence you need
it to be about
why my son got shot for no reason we
need to make sure that it's about
them not about smashing fleet cars
because that's not going to bring my son
back
now it should be noted that all they
heard was smashing police cars
and so they did uh is that his
biological mom
i i believe so again a lot of that i
yeah not all of us can be corroborated
but that's how it's being covered in
mainstream music she's white
yeah did anybody notice i noticed
i noticed that she was a beautiful
yes brave is it bbw they call it i think
so
i don't know but the point is she said
don't do this don't smash police cars
and they said smash police car she said
don't do the opposite of that
and if ever you needed a more clear
example of the disconnect
between actual justice which usually
involves waiting for information
waiting for the facts and the reason
that people are going out and rioting
and protesting and of course black lives
matter raising
over a billion dollars from these
corporations and then one of the
founders buying four 1.4 million dollar
homes and
predominantly white areas which no
problem i know what you do with your
money is none of
my business until it's a non-profit and
then it kind of is everybody else's
business that's the nature of a
non-profit
this is where we are right now here's
something too i cannot uh a hundred
percent conf i want to be clear
however this is making the rounds it
does seem that it's legitimate
um 1.2 the second he bought it
the what what'd you say i said it's
probably 1.2 the second well
yeah technically only the first one was
one point it was she it was cheap
the brooklyn center is where the riots
erupted the brooklyn center police
department they issued a press release
saying that officers determined
the driver of vehicle had an outstanding
warrant right now i have people looking
for that if you're on twitter
and you found the warrant send it to us
and we'll bring it up here later in the
show it's been a little bit difficult to
uh to find
at one point as officers were attempting
to take the driver into custody the
driver re-entered the vehicle one
officer discharged their firearm
striking the driver
the vehicle traveled several blocks
before striking another vehicle now this
is something right now
that may be from dante's arrest police
scanner audio has been making the rounds
it
seems to line up um it's pretty tough to
corroborate all this information
the morning of and of course it's really
hard when you're using google to search
for facts
uh so this is from the police scanner
audio i believe that seems to insinuate
he may have had a firearm and he
certainly was running from police
officers
[Music]
approaching lowry
happy to pursue can we confirm this is a
carjacked vehicle
a firm we talked to some cops and twos
earlier when we saw it
they said it was matching description
taken at gunpoint
whose letter had passion is on
please man he had a gun in his hand he's
going to be coming out to
paul's rich before i went on laura i
need a description
in mind this is taking about 20
something minutes blue sweatshirt light
colored pants
uh mid length so there you go there's a
description obviously of what he was
wearing when i heard a gun i heard i do
yeah
i heard two yeah i heard this at
midwestern i heard oh we're going
southbound uh you know
when i heard i heard steven avery making
a police call yeah uh
brainerd shots yeah i think this is uh
look we don't know if it's 100 accurate
but it does
seem uh to be that incident in question
again at the very least all i'm saying
here is wait before you burn someone
else's stuff down yeah
definitely not enough to do that wait
before you commit a crime because maybe
this ca
of course we sometimes are unfortunate
situations maybe this kid didn't deserve
what happened
maybe there was an outstanding warrant
like the police said and maybe he had a
firearm and was
fleeing a rest we don't know and i think
we've reached the point right now where
if you don't know you know usually we
were raised
you don't know err on the side of
caution now it's you don't know is there
something reflective nearby break it
break that [ __ ] and that is i would say
an issue not necessarily ideal
uh as a direction societally but right
now to actually explain some of this to
us because we understand and we've been
accused of quarterback
not withstanding of being tone deaf um
we have our very own uh prof
formerly professor penis and the
transgender um uh yeah
criminology he actually has been working
on a new phd
in urban criminology and here he is to
deliver actually his live thesis
on air
[Music]
all right uh how are you there professor
penis how are you doing uh well you know
we might need to get the
you might need to get a little closer to
the microphone and get the microphone on
there can we hear you
seems like we need to uh we need more
qualified professors and
i mean it seems like you're not the this
isn't your niche but you say that you
are working on something other than yeah
so as the audience is familiar i'm
professor penis i have a
phd in penis and penis related sciences
but i'm working on as you said a new new
thesis
yeah this is urban criminology and
community
response oh okay so great so you're
working on this thesis so maybe you can
explain to us
obviously right now people are confused
as to
what the possible scenarios are that
come from a scenario like this
yeah so here are the basic elements of
criminality and
crime related structures okay and i see
community interaction so you have police
these are the elements yeah so we have
police uh
police human male or female or any the
other ones
uh suspect and community reactions right
okay so let's take us through this
because it seems like right now
regardless of the verdict
that we have sort of a foregone out we
thought with shaving if regardless of
the verdict that
we're going to write turns out we don't
even have a verdict so we would like to
know
what sequence of events where the
ultimate sort of you know end game is so
let's start with yeah
yeah let's start with yeah police a
normal non-violent
traffic violence traffic violation okay
the uh
perpetrator is white yes nothing
no right nothing gets done because they
don't there will still be riots there
will be riots okay yeah that's true so
now we'll go
change the race here to blacks and
non-violent
traffic traffic violation right black if
he is just arrested and complies
riots okay he resists a bit okay he can
either get
shot or apprehended okay either way
those both will lead to okay i'm seeing
right
here right so now we can jump over to
the suspect okay so this is important
the suspect might be different from the
police interaction okay so seeing it
from other perspectives
suspect the police interaction what
happens if he
complies yeah that would be here arrest
again
which goes okay so i see that you had to
add that retroactively exactly
if he resists it combines here again
could be apprehended or shot
yeah shut up right right okay understood
for sure
uh he can call his mother or parent
figure right that's happened before with
people community will then
hear of this uh that will lead to that
okay sure let's go to the community
reaction there and i don't know if you
guys have any questions
because i feel like yes yeah and this is
your thesis correct yeah yeah this is
the main this is kind of the bulk
uh right this is the bulk of your thesis
so community reaction
uh uh community if there you know there
obviously could be a riot already
happening here right that will be
more could already be started that'll
just be more continuing is it
uh is your phd in penis or is it
uh your last name uh it's just the phd
in penis-related sciences in general
is there any sort of thing that wouldn't
lead to a riot
yeah uh that's being looked into okay
uh so far we haven't found that sure
my team mostly okay gotcha so there's
nothing that you have in your in your
thesis that you think could help us
to avoid not not at the moment okay well
i mean
of course if if they're not guilty i
mean i think we have a couple of
apprehended up there between police and
suspect
that's true what if they're not guilty
uh up there
if it does it it oh it does yeah so
let's
go to arrest not guilty uh yes
no still end up all right okay okay well
listen you know what um
it's it's at least important that we we
trusted the science so
uh professor yeah this is all this is
very yeah well i appreciate it and i uh
good luck on your thesis
and uh be sure to uh you know take take
take the back roads
yeah i had a preliminary grade already
the other oh that's right
you already submitted the thesis yeah uh
it was yeah peer reviewed i got a solid
c plus i kind of haggled up to a b minus
range
so yeah good yeah solid b thank you all
right professor penis everybody
thank you
[Music]
we need better scientists i mean he's
he's out of his dad he's
he's getting used to this i only follow
the science until they uh pull it off
youtube
right yeah i only follow the science
that youtube allows me to follow then it
doesn't exist
yeah it's not on youtube it's like if a
tree falls in the woods
or like you know a riot yeah
so riot takes place in the woods is
fouchy there to justify it yeah
you don't know we have no idea he does
look like he makes cookies in a tree
he does he's like stop burning down my
house he does look like he also might
moonlight as someone in a gingerbread
house
who uh ultimately gets you know shoved
in the oven by angry children who didn't
want to be baked
really he looks like the there's no
redemption in the hands of ingredients
when you think about it like it's not
like oh they learned how to love
they just shove that [ __ ] in the oven
what's good for the game
it's awesome that's what you should do i
mean if somebody tries to eat
your kids you're going to be like look
push the [ __ ] in the oven
that really is the only just outcome it
is
a teacher they were bad kids their
parents left them in the woods before we
move on i want to go back to one thing
the lady who lived in a shoe was she was
just a [ __ ] but yeah that was a shrew
yeah a lot of cats
you know you made a good point people
need to wait right there two
opposite options right he was running
back to his car yelling i'm going to get
my gun to kill you right that's an
option and then police react or running
back to his car hey i forgot my idea is
that cool
right you know like there's we have no
idea what he was doing yet but
it really is hard to hold an opinion
when elected officials come out and say
and i can't remember who said this in
minneapolis said
um we've i regret that we've lost
another black man
to police officer shooting again right
so yeah really highlighting these points
and saying oh it happened again and
again go back go back to the other stuff
that we've been talking about with
maxine water and other
politicians coming out and saying this
is racism
it's hard to hold well by the way the
reason that they were there so quickly
was i believe there was already a black
panthers
protest going on there in town already
so they got there
yeah it was just like a two two for one
and they and they already they burned
down the brooklyn center by the way a
liquor store and stuff really harmed
people in their own
when i say they i mean people in this
community right regardless of race look
there's obviously a demographic in the
community but the fact is
the person harmed the person whose
liquor store was ransacked and burned
down
was likely a part of that demographic in
the community yeah this
is not going to end i don't know
look talk about frog in boiling water
it's boiling it's boiling at this point
we're at a point right now where
youtube's well you can't say that
because maybe that's offensive well you
can't now it's
you can't be a doctor you can't be a
scientist from harvard
and quote the cdc data or the world
health organizat if they don't go
together
on any given day yeah and now you cannot
you cannot speak out against riotous
barbarism
in the without being accused of being
racist well you know what you know who
wants more police presence than we
currently have
most black people in this country these
people in these communities are the ones
who suffer most and you see that mom
right there saying hey look please stop
please stop this right let's not they do
it anyway
well the whole the barbarism needs to
fade get it
i see what you're saying there well the
whole reason that they banned donald
trump was that
speech led to violence right they're
saying oh but your speech about
elections has led to violence and so we
can't have that
what do you think a statement like that
from from an elected official in your
state saying i can't believe we lost
another black man to police brutality
basically or to a police shooting i
should say what do you think that is
pushing people towards thinking
like oh it's happened again it's the
same thing we've been fighting again
that doesn't lead to
here's this is entirely conjecture okay
but here's my bet because then they say
look and then then they came back and
riot gear later and took the body left
him on the side of the road and came
back and riot gear later took the body
while the
well everyone was grieving here's my bet
if i have to bet what happened
entirely conjecture i cannot corroborate
this this is just
a hunch you can come back and tell me if
i'm wrong kind of like when we watched
the the joe biden a press briefing
whatever it was called the first press
conference live
and i happened to be right i was three
for three my prediction here is what
most likely happened is
on the front end some kind of a
miscommunication most likely a guy had a
warrant i tend to believe that the cops
are being accurate about that maybe he
had a gun
looks like we have the warrants we do
have the warrants okay let's bring up
this warrant this is happening live
right now we have we have two this one
was for uh possession
sale of small amounts of marijuana okay
and then this one
this one was for disorderly conduct but
he
let's see he um he was called into court
and to pay fines and he never paid the
fine and he never never got it in court
so then so there's
more points where issued for his arrest
and that doesn't sound like that's a big
deal but the issue there is if you don't
show up in court
again if it's well what if i don't want
to pay the fines look at a certain point
there has to be some accountability so
one time there was a warrant out for my
arrest yeah that's right
i tried to turn down about the money no
you know exactly what happened was i got
it
this is true i got a speeding ticket in
ann arbor michigan yeah
and uh it was a total speed trap where
it goes from 40 to 20 and then to 40 for
about two blocks and a cop sits right
there
angry little lesbian cop and uh and she
was she was
angry and she was lesbian i don't see
that no she was angry
both i know usually it's one or the
other i know i've never seen it combined
and she came up she gave me a ticket it
was in my wife's car at the time
it was in a car that wasn't mine in a
state where i didn't live and they
posted it to some
address where i had never been so i
never got the ticket in the mail
completely forgot about it
turned out that since i didn't pay it
there was a warrant and i went in and i
paid it they just okay you just need to
pay a fine it was reduced to
less than a traffic violation because i
was going like five over yeah but
the point is i had to go into court the
cop said you cannot drive in the car
right now
switch with your wife right now who's a
passenger and i complained okay
completely forgot about this ticket the
point is
do i think that someone should uh be
arrested for
marijuana no i don't i don't believe
that nonviolent drug offenders need to
be arrested however if there's
disorderly conduct there's a white
umbrella there we don't know what
happened
there needs to be some kind of justice
there needs to be a hashing out process
if you don't show up in court at some
point they're going to have to arrest
you so here's my bet
let me just kind of give you what i
think is most likely here police say
okay there's a warrant here there's some
kind of a traffic violation he knows
there's a warrant out for his arrest
he gets disorderly obviously this guy
has a history of being disorderly maybe
he has a gun
maybe he doesn't maybe he flees maybe he
goes to grab the gun like a jacob blake
scenario
someone gets he gets shot now what
happens the reason why
why did he leave his body on the side of
the road my guess is what probably
happened since they had a black panthers
rally right nearby
is they realized this is going to be a
heated scenario protesters are already
here
so they left came back with riot gear to
protect themselves and retrieve the body
that would be my guess come on back and
tell me when i'm wrong i have no idea
this is just my guess with the
information that's available to me
certainly not a reason to riot and burn
down your neighbor's
stuff hey what happened to christianity
doesn't that matter how about something
about being good to your neighbor
even if your neighbor's a cop in this
instance it's not even a cop
it's a guy who serves your community
with
i don't know liquor and ring dings i'm
not saying he's a prophet
just saying you shouldn't burn down his
stuff and steal his
crap by the way we're on instagram
louder with crowder uh
we're a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern that's the best
way to just watch us follow us and of
course crowdershop.com we'll be taking
your chat a little bit later on
when we are mug club only you can buy
these uh shirts at crowder shop
merch it's wonderful piss off shirts
that's our favorite one
about to say something there gerald
smith well i i think you're uh i think
you're right this happened again in
hennepin county though these guys are uh
continuously very busy i don't know if
that's where the shove and stuff this
was 10 miles away from there when this
happened and you know
that right now they're worried about
riots just from stuff coming out of the
trial right
much less something like this happening
so everybody should have been like hey
guys
hold on wait until we know what's going
on i've actually just got something from
hennepin county that's a little more
severe than a
marijuana really oh yeah this is on
dante
um this was in february
early february of this year uh
aggravated robbery i don't know
oh and he was released from custody
um but that that was uh he could have
gotten
sick he could have yeah he could have
been released like takashi 6 9 where he
got early release because of his asthma
like piggy from lord of the flies after
ratting out gang members yeah
sure if that was our gangster rappers
when we were young used to actually
shoot each other in the face yeah
i remember when nwa had all rainbow hair
that was cool yeah
what a bunch of awful [ __ ] i hate
what's happened to him
you're sitting there yeah i remember
iced tea [ __ ] the police gotta grab my
inhaler
[ __ ] name ice cube make sure you
roll over on a brother
yeah i mean think about this just please
yeah the the marijuana bail
was 300 this this felony this aggravated
uh robbery was a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand bail
so if he was released and then let's say
there was another there was but then
there was an outstanding warrant so
maybe does that seem like the disorderly
conduct happened after the armed robbery
because that would maybe mean okay armed
robbery disorderly conduct and now
you're going back to the clink for a
long time no no no the the disorderly
conduct and the marijuana charges were
from like august of 2019. that was
before the robbery so what was the
outstanding warrant
for yeah it looks like this might have
been for the robbery
but how did he but they let him up they
let him free
yeah okay he may have strong
so maybe it was conditional release
because of kovid something like that but
the point is okay so look now we're
talking about armed robbery a very
expensive bail being set
and being pulled over by the police it's
it's just there's always more to this
and
if you know crime statistics people act
out of desperation when they don't want
to go to prison right
do we know that it's for armed robbery
is that what it is officially well
that's what we know that trying to
figure
out is convicted about was he charged
with we know we know aggravated just
curious
about armed sorry aggravated well it
sounds like aggravated robbery
i'd be aggravated if i were robbed like
you're aggravating me you little bastard
been aggravated i took the last 20 out
of my atm account i was 19. i'm like
what are you
come on all right well keep us updated
as more stuff comes in um
right this is the issue right it doesn't
i'm hoping that maybe this at least
allows
the shoving jurors to get rid of the
guilt
get rid of like hey listen it's on you
if this town burns like well it was
already burning before we even got to a
verdict before you're in halfway through
the trial so you know what
now let's just look at the facts and
hopefully try and administer justice
how about we get to that right everyone
on board everyone well how about we
punish the people that are destroying
property
oh no those are protesters
but are they mostly peaceful as long as
they're mostly as long as they're mostly
people
what's funny is this mostly peaceful
means partially violent
yeah islam is also mostly peaceful as
well and that never
yeah if you were to attend any protest
or
any rally or any concert any event with
large people and were advertised
as partially violent oh you know what i
think i might stay home
i knew i should have stayed home today
but now it's been mostly peaceful yeah
how many
2 billion dollars in damages and that's
just the insurance and keep in mind
we're about to get to
joe biden's executive orders on guns
right which by the way we have tomorrow
would change my mind on this topic and
then we have the voter id one coming up
next week
he talked about the cost to the american
taxpayer of guns you know some
astronomical trillions of dollars or
hundreds of billions because
hospitals legal fees okay so when we use
the number
riots we're just talking about two
billion dollars in damages yeah
with insurance costs not the hundreds of
officer casualties casualties by the way
include deaths and serious injuries
not the dozens of deaths right we're not
talking about the thousands of arrests
so how many trillions is that costing
americans overall
in trials in legal fees in appeals
in hospital bills it needs to go both
ways we're just quoting the lowest
number that two billion dollars in
damages that will be recouped
with private insurance companies i'm
sorry
look i don't know i mean i want to be a
happy warrior people talk about i don't
know if we're around the bend at this
point
you can't speak about your rights being
infringed upon you can't speak about
your rights being stripped away by
a foreign entity with the world health
organization by the way like you said
doesn't even agree with the cdc
and now you're not supposed to be able
to speak out against
billions of dollars in damages in people
being
beaten to death in the streets yeah talk
about
wrong think we're look behind you we're
way past orwellian
and now let's get to speaking of rights
being stripped away and by the way you
let me know uh
the best thing you do is hit like
comment comment comment where
where do you think we are along the
spectrum now to surf them
george orwell would be like hey guys
there's just stories yeah guys
you guys gotta slow down someone would
submit this right for him and be like
hey here's my new now like oh look
no one's gonna buy that that's why i
made them animals
in animal farm you have to make the
characters three-dimensional you can't
just
just this joseph but you can't just make
him a total [ __ ]
there's no relatability i mean the pigs
weren't wearing masks in my novel wait
come on now
if you've been listening to too much
white albums yeah these kids
uh okay so let's get to the biden
executive orders on guns and this is the
interesting thing again this is how the
media
uh ends up disseminating this
information this is their understanding
of firearms joy behar uh has also said
that she has never seen
a gun in real life people have talked
about this
yeah what about that's what she said at
some point that's my fault talk about
elitist she's like i've never seen it
i've never seen a gun i've never used a
gun she is surrounded by people with
guns so she doesn't have to get her
hands dirty herself
how have you not seen a gun i you know
what i
being a liar yeah that's the only way no
way
why would i need a gun uh i don't know
why does everyone around your building
at abc need firearms remember i did that
when i was on the sky news or bbc yeah
and then i said to americans why do you
always need a whole carry a gun you can
search us on youtube as i said i don't
know i have a gun on me right now
well i uh hope well why would you need
that i said you're surrounded by people
with guns right there and she goes
uh no or not maybe you don't have people
with m16s in the studio but i know
that the sky news and bbc studios are
protected by heavily armed security
and then he ended by saying i hope the
safety latches there's no such thing as
a safety latch
this is why we left your country it's
not a cabinet with a two-year-old in the
house you
dumb [ __ ] all right
so let's go to buy now the executive
orders on gun
uh on gun control and here is the view
it's just perfect because rather than
straw manning this shows the amount of
understanding that those in the media
have as it relates to firearms and then
we'll go to each individual claim
you know when he says it's an
international embarrassment i like it
and they'll happen here like somebody
got shot and then the cop will say what
are we in the united states
i mean we are an international
embarrassment just like he says
speak for yourself she's talking about
the views specifically
you know they'll never uh possibly have
control of the house the senate and the
white house
again so i say push through whatever is
needed and hope that congress comes to
their senses
well after that she pushed through her
metamucil
brought to you in part by fiber blow
i gotta go all the time i gotta go all
the time
i used to have to eat wicker rocking
chairs
that's a good thing so this is some of
these are some of the claims that they
make here's the thing that they're
talking about quite a bit right now
ghost guns right so joe biden uh is
wanting to mandate serial numbers and he
wants to run background checks here he
is talking about
ghost guns that's the word of the day
and today i'm announcing several initial
steps my administration is taking
to curb this epidemic of gun violence
much more need be done but the first
first want to reign in the proliferation
of so-called ghost
guns he needs a joy basis
built from a kit and include directions
on how to finish the firearm you can go
buy the kit they have no serial numbers
so when they show up at a crime scene
they can't be traced
and the buyers aren't required to pass a
background check to buy the kit
to make the gun what a file a nail file
anyone from uh what an [ __ ] to a
terrorist
can buy this kit as little as 30 minutes
put together next thing he's going to
ban
connects i want to see these kits
more tinker treated as firearms under
the gun control act
which is going to require that the
seller and manufacturers
make the key parts with serial numbers
ah
they run background checks on the buyers
when they walk in to buy
that package
what's the word what's word package by
the way uh this is he wants to be really
afraid of ghost guns because of course
uh here's one of those ghost guns uh in
use
when did you kill that bird ass
[Music]
that was the first ghost gun gary
malkovich sticks the bullet in his
rabbits
in the line of fire okay so first thing
it's very very easy to make a firearm
just so you know okay
and uh that's not illegal to make a
firearm at home if you have a pipe and
some copper wiring you can make a
firearm
yeah serial numbers are totally
irrelevant here's why they only
track the firearm to the first bill of
sale okay let's be clear yeah uh by the
way hit the notification bell because uh
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
just know that we're live uh
monday through thursday 10 years they
should have serial numbers though so his
son can't throw them into a
[Laughter]
so playground son can't put them in a
kiddie pool filter let's go see if there
are frogs in the filter no
smith and wesson
come on man so here's the thing ghost
guns as they call them
it means basic this is a back door to
try and ban parts
okay to be clear and i this firearm
right here okay this firearm right here
i
did what what is called a trigger job
you watch out for that yeah you gotta
watch out for the firemen it might
be it's gonna get you don't piss it off
um
i got a ghost one in the car no you just
reach for it
not there it's like pig pens cloud
so ghost guns are very rarely used
in uh in any kind of actual uh criminal
altercations now here's something too i
was trying to create rebuttals for this
argument getting ready for it changed my
mind based on the data available
however it is such [ __ ] that it's
impossible to actually create rebuttal
arguments so here's where you go if you
go to nbc or abc we'll have all the
sources available at large credit.com
says oh 30 of guns recovered by the atf
are ghost guns that was the first source
and i'm going okay well let me look into
this then i go oh no wait a second
it actually says 30 of firearms are
covered by the atf in california
are ghost guns and i thought well okay
let me start writing this out that's
kind of ironic that it's a typically gun
restrictive state and then i read i
don't know
it's 30 of guns recovered in california
from the atf
don't have serial numbers and so they
throw all the ghost guns
into there and then i realized there was
no actual report it was allegedly uh
a verbal report given to some local nbc
news reporter
and so i couldn't prepare for anything
because it's all lies
so this counts if you filed off the the
yes yeah
wow yes you can buy the kit yes you can
buy the kit
it's a beckett you go into any store and
you're like i need the ghost gun kit
and they're like okay right here sir
again what does this
do when he talks about it makes it the
kit some people talk about that for
example i have a rifle and there's a
different receiver that you can put in
so it fires 22
ammunition yeah right and that makes it
far less expensive
this ends up creating a barrier to entry
for the most poor among us to train
people who might need to defend
themselves and i don't know
cities that are being burned alive
so out of the 287 000 prisoners surveyed
by the bureau of justice
seven percent purchased guns from
federal uh firearms license dealers
56 either had stolen it found it at the
scene of the crime or
obtained it off the black market and
there's another 25 percent who basically
just had it give it to them
um now here's an interview too even from
the uh i believe assistant director of
the atf i don't know if he's the current
assistant director because there's been
a lot of turnover
uh thomas chittim admitted uh that ghost
guns here he is telling you the real
threat of ghost guns it's not a thing
you're on the streets you have no idea
uh no
philly and how many crimes are being
committed by these
guns you have no idea well not with
precision they still represent
a minority of the firearms that are
being used in crimes but we do see
they're increasing significantly and
rapidly
look if your goal is to keep people safe
how about you give something more than
uh well minority increasing with
significance and uh rapidly tepidly
lukewarm like come on give us something
to go on you're supposed to be the
expert have an
idea come in the other room i say
minority when he said minority
i think he did i think he really did
where he said minority to minority
he's like oh that was my what you said
oh that was you that was me i was
looking at the screen i'm like why would
i but it would add up if they never mind
swinging a miss dave that was me it was
mia swinging on this
here's another thing that they're
talking about with the executive orders
none of these would do anything by the
way these are
all about control of backdoor gun
registry
banning your ability to get parts these
are infringements on your second
amendment rights
bent doors by the way you'll hear this
tomorrow when we did we did a uh
uh changed my mind on red flag laws
every single person who thought they
supported red flag laws
sat down we'll have this up tomorrow
read the policies
from the white house website and when i
explained them immediately opposed it
so you may think you support red flag
laws you don't
let me explain because that's the
biggest part is legislation you
absolutely shouldn't it's one of those
things that sounds nice and
compassionate and empathetic
and it just ends up in an increase in
crime and more uh
women getting raped because they're
weaker than men and the firearm is a
great equalizer
so thanks samuel colt but sorry we've
decided that we've progressed beyond
giving women the ability to defend
themselves here's another claim that
they're making he's saying that
he wants to subject modified pistols to
fees and a national registry to reduce
gun violence here he is former vice
president joe biden
we want to treat pistols modified with
stabilizing braces
with the seriousness they deserve a
stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a hell of a lot more
accurate than a mini rifle
that's like an ace bandage on your
pistol
effectively turn it into a short
barreled rifle oh my god
that's what the alleged shooter in
boulder appears to have done i don't
have the strength
to shoot no more that these
modifications to fire rheumatoid
arthritis more lethal
the national firearms that are too many
capers national firearms act requires
that a potential owner pay 200 fee and
submit
their name and other identify
information to the justice department
there you go there's a registry a
national registry we've also seen of
course people who have suggested that a
national registry be made available
to the public this is not something
that's extreme or fringe from the left
wing today
and by the here's something that's all
many registries do i have to be on
i don't know i'd be more concerned with
making sure that all of your neighbors
in your immediate vicinity
sign off i bring them pie but they won't
eat it i tell them why i'm there
this is the thing with the national gun
registry first off it's unconstitutional
it's wrong okay
and we're talking about pistols pistols
are already more heavily regulated than
rifles
okay and he's saying hey they might take
a pistol and turn it into a rifle a
pistol
which is used in more shootings and
turning them to a rifle which is not
yeah but when i bought one there's a
waiting period yes depends where you buy
one
um it depends in michigan there's a
wedding period
well for a handgun see there wasn't one
i bought i don't think so maybe
i had to wait a couple days maybe
because your background check took a
while to go they probably just went
okay let me type this in and well i
think that we're gonna have to call you
back yeah
i think that may have been either the
case or there were so many because of
the riots because
there was a point where michigan was
running out of ammo and got like
everywhere
we're still doing that yeah you could
hear that right as that speech was going
you could hear
the sound of gun sales increasing of the
demand
it sounds like a whistle it's a it's a
it's a woozy it's a wazi
fairy dust it's not real so um pistols
are already more regulated than
long guns okay 44 states allow open
carry of
long guns rifles compared to just 33
allowing open carry of handguns again
200
fee mandatory reporting to the doj
that's effectively a backdoor gun
registry not to mention maybe it becomes
annual
yeah not to mention what if someone and
here's something too not everyone but
the reason for these stabilizing braces
a lot of time was for people with
disabilities or you were kind of joking
but seniors who have trouble controlling
some of these firearms
if you believe that right now we have an
epidemic
of pistols with an ace bandage around a
copper tube
in a tube sock or a tennis ball like at
the end of a walker that that is why
we have mass shootings in this country
and across the industrialized world
we're not even in the top five
then well you might i suggest you're
misinformed but i would also suggest
that in the general sense
uh people who believe that don't they're
lying
joe biden basically just made the
argument that if anything out there
makes a gun
more accurate it should be gotten rid of
so sites are next you've got a file
office how are you going to fire it into
the air on the porch two times
if you got a stabilizing price well you
know you're gonna have to aim and line
up the sights just go
yeah he said like yosemite sam he said
if you have the brace on he literally
said it makes it more accurate and
therefore more deadly
i thought that was the point correct i
thought to defend myself i didn't want
to miss 74 times before i finally hit
flash
if i have a brace i want it to be more
deadly through accuracy
to the intended target yes if i don't
it's more deadly
to everyone around i don't i mean
seriously that was the argument that the
former vice president united states just
made on national television
i got a whole list of things that could
make a last-minute silencer including a
pumpkin
an old well i guess dr pepper bottle
because won't be coca-cola won't have
that in my house
dr pepper is delightful mr pibb and i
don't know anything about mystery you
don't know mr pip i know what it is
it's his uneducated brother
just a mister change the last name
because dr pepper forced him to
you can't carry the peppermantle anymore
that's fair
now um here's another thing this is the
most uh pervasive this is the most
pernicious this is the most subversive
take any objective that you want red
flag laws he's implying here that they
would reduce suicides domestic violence
incidents mash
this is uh the crux
of what they want to do because it
grants them the most amount of control
and i will say this red flag laws as he
is outlining them
would be the greatest violation of your
fundamental human rights
that we've endured in our lifetime so
let me show you what he's claiming
and then let me explain to you why that
is and why every single person that
changed my mind that's coming out
tomorrow liberals mind you
vaccine virtue signalers said oh wow now
that i know what it is no of course i
don't support that yeah
here's his claim i wanted to make it
easier for states to adopt
extreme risk protection order laws
they're also called
red flag laws which everybody in this
law
knows but many people listening do not
know
these laws allow a police or family
member
to petition a court in their
jurisdiction
and say i want you to temporarily move
from the following people
any firearm they may possess
because they're a danger and a crisis
they're presenting a danger to
themselves
and to others okay so first off i often
say that at first
uh glance at first hearing that you go
okay that makes sense if you just listen
to what he said and you didn't get
chills down your spine
you don't know what you were hearing
that doesn't even start off
from a point of making sense let me be
clear here okay
right now if you're a violent felon you
cannot purchase a firearm
right now if you're a violent domestic
abuser you cannot legally purchase a
firearm
okay these are already laws and of
course there are background checks that
already exist
the red flag laws which by the way have
been happening state to state so we have
some evidence as to how they've been
abused but he wants to set a
national sort of template for a red flag
law
within 60 days and then make it easier
and of course
exert pressure on states to adopt it
what does this actually mean
a red flag law he just said police or
family member police
family member friends neighbors doctors
basically they can say
hey this person is a danger and i don't
think that they should have firearms and
so
you right now having not committed a
crime
having been convicted of no crime
charged of no crime
not even having had a trial or the
opportunity to face your accusers
can have the police come into your house
in the middle of the night
and seize your firearms and then later
on down the line maybe you get to go to
court and the judge decides that uh
we'll consider giving it back this is a
violation of due process
it obviously has told it completely
disregards the laws that we already have
i also should have clarified
if you're uh adjudicated mentally
defective by a court we have that
process right now in other words if
you've already displayed behavior that
you were a threat to yourself
or others they can take your firearms
away this makes it entirely subjective
no due process no crime no charge
your guns are gone imagine you're in a
city with riots
going on right now you're a woman maybe
you already lost your husband
like david dorn maybe you already lost
the protector of the house
and you have some kids and a firearm to
protect yourself and your neighbor says
you know what
i don't like her uh i think she's
mentally defective
okay thank you good enough for me you're
saying well that won't happen well let
me give you some examples of states
defensive so new jersey under a new red
flag law
a man's guns were confiscated after his
doctor reported him
for leaving bad reviews and an agitated
phone call due to severe post-surgery
pain
yeah you lose your second amount you
lose your god-given right to
self-preservation
because of yelp comments
rhode island woman called the cops on
her husband uh a guy was named edward
kennedy edward coniglia edward caligula
after an argument requested that they
conduct a wellness check the police
deemed the husband to be an imminent
danger to himself and others compensated
his guns
and then requested that he went uh under
a psych evaluation the case is currently
now in front of the supreme court
so wow this is something this does
happen
look and i understand people saying we
want to be safe and there's been some
shooters who
they were on the fb the fbi should have
done something i understand but at a
certain point
when people say hey hey hey if it saves
one life
that's not an argument no and it's also
a really bad argument because guess what
firearms are used defensively in a
minimum of five hundred thousand times
two three million times in a year you
know how many homicides with firearms in
this country per year
fourteen thousand yeah they defend far
more lives than they take and it is
a violation of fundamental human rights
to take
away an equalizer from the most
vulnerable among us
especially if they have not committed a
crime you don't
do you understand what you're giving up
say well yeah you know about some crazy
you know what hey
look if we don't go with red flag wells
what do we have we have violent felons
can't get firearms violent domestic
abusers can't people who've already been
adjudicated mentally defective through
the courts have gone to the system can't
get them
will some psychopaths maybe slip through
those are the consequences of living in
a free society oh how much is your life
worth well you know what how much is the
they use this argument for everything
you've collapsed the economy
for decades to come record suicides
good thing is the flu doesn't exist
anymore deaths are basically down to
zero so that's nice
you say how much is your life worth how
much is my livelihood worth how much are
our freedoms worth
how much are the lives of the three
million people who defended them
each year with firearms worth it's not a
valid argument and at a certain point if
you say
i'm willing to give up my rights for
some minority report
dystopian future where they can take
away my rights pre-crime
look thank you for supporting it because
i now identify you as the enemy we will
have no
common ground i will find no common
ground i will fake no common ground with
someone who thinks
they should be able to call the cops and
take my guns away with me having never
committed a crime no center
no middle ground we're not friends
you're my enemy yeah well and think
about it this way so people are like oh
that's some distant future well in 2016
if you supported donald trump you
weren't considered a radical yet maybe a
racist because that was the label
yes now let's fast forward to january
6th of this year let's say that you were
i was saying that you are no i'm not i i
disagree and a radical yeah
i'm radically racist a parent yes okay
i'm a fine young vertical january 6th
you attend
a rally you're not one of the people who
stormed the capital you're just somebody
who goes up there because you support
donald trump now you go back to your
liberal state of california and your
neighbors know that you attended that
rally everybody's labeled an
insurrectionist you've got a donald
trump flag
they make a phone call that is the
scenario that you are now living under
because you support the wrong person
right the irs targeted under barack
obama targeted tea party groups
conservative groups yeah
people for some reason this is the thing
with liberals when remember we went to
you were a punk rock had no fx and rock
against bush and corruption and uh
capital crony capitalism it all went
away when barack obama was president
yeah
remember all of a sudden the films about
political corruption went away
and they came back under trump and now
they're going to go away again because
inherently democrats are good look i
believe that all human beings are flawed
and evil okay as a christian we are all
inherently selfish and sinful
donald trump included ted cruz included
desantis included which is why i don't
want them to have
that much power you think oh no no no
republicans are evil but joe biden of
course would never abuse my rights
barack obama would never abuse my rights
let's give them all the rights let's
pack the court
let's give up our firearm rights let's
remove due process because
i know that joe biden really has his
[ __ ] together after all he's had 64
years in public office to get it right
literally his shit's probably not
together together i assume it's very
running you know i i hate that's a good
point
i hate to make this reference but i
think if we don't look at the greatest
tragedy in history for
rights being taken away then we we miss
a lot of the lessons what was the one of
the first things that happened in
germany was
jews were basically put on a red flag
list because they were jewish it wasn't
just them though
it was gypsies and other undesirable
peoples and this could not
happen and they exactly nobody talks
about it because they think it's a third
nobody
tells me anything yeah they took their
guns away from all of those people
groups so that when the next steps
happened
you couldn't defend yourself right at
all they had no ability and they
encouraged
neighbors to germany i'm saying that
there are consequences when these
look what happened look what happened
with theoretically in genocide look what
happened in china
look what happened in russia and people
trying to go yo look what happened in
australia uh yeah you implemented a gun
ban and then gun ownership and crime
went up
but they've got a lot of deadly animals
oh that's yeah even in australia
it was british well they were from
british yeah they were
they were they were all the rapists yeah
that's why the place was so cool
music i wanted to be
as soon as i get off the plane yep i
don't have any interest in going to
europe
or by extension australia i would ride a
kangaroo all over the place
i would dress like crocodile dundee
because i know they love bull hogan over
there they would welcome you with open
arms drive around in a subaru be like
next time you go to the just for last
festival in montreal go dressed up as a
mountie
i'm pretty sure i won't you're back
there i only
won't either i was on pantalos at a mike
awards show and i basically just
insulted the whole festival on how
pompous it was
that's pretty much the whole city here's
something else too by the way uh
we have to i don't even know if we're
gonna we have we have uh you know david
hogg just left
seven plus one day oh he's the best
david hogg my
my pal no
this is something else too joe biden is
doing not a lot of people are paying
attention nominating david shipman to
serve as the director for the atf
saying that it'll reduce gun violence
here's something people uh really should
know chipman spent 25 years
as a special agent in the atf currently
works as a senior policy advisor at
giffords
research organization that of course
promotes gun control aggressively
sometimes mandatory buybacks like
australia he was an agent for the atf
during the waco it's at the branch
davidian truck
here's the thing wherever you line up
you guys should do some research on on
waco
look cult sure guys a little nutty
sure understood you don't go in and burn
down the women in children and by the
way the atf
at that point what they could have done
was uh
corrections could have arrested koresh
when he went into town to get coffee
like he did
every day people have the right to be a
cult
and live off in their own commune if
they're not causing problems
and so janet reno who by the way is
probably likely the first
uh transgender female in office before
rachel levine made up some scheme that
oh they were molesting kids and abusing
kids turns out that that wasn't very
likely true but even if it were true
then why would you bulldoze the front
door kill the dogs and kill all the
women and children
anyone as far as i'm concerned anyone
involved with the waco branch davidian
situation who worked
they should have all been fired
permanently and this guy is now going to
be the head
of the atf also worked with the atf when
the fast and furious scandal happened
under barack obama i don't have time to
get into this
fast and furious gun walker these are
the terms that you can use what happened
was
the atf knowingly allowed firearms to be
trafficked across the southern border
and then they were used to kill border
patrol agents
wow anyone involved with it should be
fired
this is the revolving door of
lagoon swamp creatures anywhere else
this guy would be fired immediately yeah
well and it makes me feel better though
that joe biden referred to it as the aft
for the entire time that he was
nominating
look if anybody started worshipping
david crush because they saw him play
guitar they might have deserved it
oh come on i'm just just saying it's too
soon
you think you think tear gas is a
violation of the geneva convention
he really did we heard his mixed tape
he's
really good i'm not really sure if we're
going by nato guidelines almost guess
myself he's like jimi hendrix if he
wasn't very good
yeah well he was definitely crazy so
you're dead you're right he was very
much crazy but he has the right to be
crazy as long as he's not hurting
anybody well the progression
aren't being held against their will
yeah exactly the progression of a cult
is just hey
uh you should come join me and we're
we're going to live as a family and then
10 minutes later it's like you know i
should have sex with
away the your right yeah of sex at home
and everybody's like yeah i guess
yeah it doesn't make sense because you
know listen if you if you have sex with
your wife you're going to be you're
going to
deal with all kinds of temptations and i
don't know and i don't got the
temptation
so i think so then you should usually
have sex with but i should you don't
mind right
i'm just going to put this in here you
don't mind you have a problem it's like
well i kind of do
i'm not sure this guy wants to go to
heaven
not a true believer ah big failure
and then they come through with a
bulldozer and kill all the women and
children thanks
aft it really is sad he was thinking
about america's funniest home videos
i i can't yeah above ground pool it
breaks
they're all over the yard i'd give
somebody who seems smart
but he's not i feel like it was always
an above ground pool breaker yeah that
was
well yeah here's another claim from joe
biden we gotta get through this now that
nobody needs a hundred bullets which by
the way
uh is not based on anything but here is
his claim in the
reason someone needs a weapon of war
with 100 rounds
100 bullets is if you don't have a bomb
you piece of [ __ ]
from that website but
what is he thinking people
like the valentine's day massacre where
someone's coming out with a model t like
all right boys dead men tell no tales
drum magazine it's incredibly rare and
by the way the assault weapons ban that
he keeps referring to
banned magazines with 10 rounds or more
and that's most firearms okay
so it's not about 100 rounds if he
wanted to ban over 100 rounds it would
still be a problem because again it's
just a backdoor to violate fundamental
human rights but that's not what he's
talking about doing
by the way this is also important when
people talk about magazine capacity
because the assault weapons ban uh it
banned uh magazine capacities over
10 rounds yeah that's why i had the
bullet button in california i got a cz
75 one time that was
i bought it in michigan it was a
california gun so all the magazines
basically
they would have to hollow it out and put
a shortened spring okay yeah and so all
of these aftermarket california
magazines were incredibly unreliable and
there's a magazine shortage so
i've never actually owned a cz 75 that
worked properly which is supposed to be
a fantastic reliable firearm
but california effed it up so
wait they give you bullets that don't
work right no what they do is so a
magazine right yeah any magazine like oh
with the spring i guess
they kind of hollow out the bottom part
of the magazine so you can only load the
spring down halfway at least that was
this firearm oh that makes sense yeah
yeah yeah because i can't you know i
can't find a way to macgyver that [ __ ]
no or just i don't know
walk over to arizona or
make the gun more touchy is always a
good idea that's always a good idea
so here's something else people say why
would you need that kind of capacity
okay a couple of things first off police
switched to semi-automatic uh firearms
after there were some there was a big
shootout in miami right because they
felt that they were outgunned by
criminals and revolvers weren't going to
do it anymore
it's estimated to take about 12 shots to
incapacitate
an intruder okay that's the average wow
now uh also the number of assailants in
violent encounters are going up they've
been going up by the decade
so it used to be you know maybe like
what he thought some guy with a drum
magazine and
all right hand over the cash see but now
the whole girls begin yeah yeah
that's in the whole loan it's a
valentine's day massacre we only met we
only massacre on valentine's day
see then we steal art on st patrick's
day
bootleggers that's our schedule why
stick to the schedule and be no
surprises steal out on st
patty's day in uh massacre on
valentine's day people back then should
have gotten away with everything
should've gotten away
never got that hope diamond so 12 rounds
per
uh intruder and now you're averaging
depending on which sources you use
two three four you better hope that you
have more than
two shots and you better hope that if
you have a double-barreled shotgun you
didn't fire it into the air illegally on
the porch as former vice president joe
biden
advise you to do um and by the way this
is
the use of high-capacity guns it stayed
steady or it's increased since the
assault weapons ban just to be clear
this is something that they claim the
assault weapons ban it didn't affect
crime whatsoever
it actually ended up uh just increasing
uh gun sales and uh right now we just
had we just crossed 400
i believe 400 million guns in the united
states freedom so joe biden
you are the firearm industries salesman
of the month
you know what i want one of those
reporters to do and then every other
reporter after
is just ask him okay tell me which
specific shootings this would have
stopped that you've been reporting on as
mass shootings or whatever you're
which ones go yeah i'm waiting come on
man
you know the one no one then no the one
that happened at the school
where had the pistol with the ace
bandage and the tennis ball
and he went there and he said hey come
get some and he said we don't want any
and then he went home and he took a nap
but then we caught him
yeah the one with the combine
so you mean none mr former vice
president oh you know the thing
no i don't i'm asking you to explain the
one with the show
the one at the school after the kid
picked up the hunter one in the trash
can oh you mean with your son who lied
on a federal firearms form that's right
and the
bruins that's the one no
brave recovery advocate right
threw an unserialized firearm into a
recycling bin at a great school
but he was going down on a guy for
parmesan cheese
no you haven't you see you're giving him
far too much credit you have no idea how
far he felt it was for velveeta oh
that's
true really oh the goop he was trying to
go he's like parmesan all right
i'll take the velveeta
shells and cheese jesus no i have
standards
no okay
no that's the can of cheese that's the
canyon guys get your mind get your mind
out of the hunter
um well played so here's another thing
too
uh i don't know if he's lying or if he's
just this stupid but former vice
president joe biden seems to be lying
because he acts as though the gun show
loophole
is a thing people don't know you walk
into a store and you buy a gun you have
a background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
okay so um i'm gonna go with lying
because barack obama did this exact same
thing
really the gun show loophole keep in
mind by the way washington post gave
this claim under obama
four pinocchios i think yeah you have
that right from washington post
two pinocchios two two two two
pinocchios all right so not quite but
they're getting there by the way that's
a
it very sexual weird on his face his
face
his face is flush from the arousal
so they even gave it to pinocchio's and
i tested a long time ago just show you
there's nothing new under the sun
from the democrats we went to i believe
it was crown heights in indiana the
specific
gun show where he claimed this was
happening as well as we went to some
local gun shops
this video is available maybe we'll
upload it again to crowder [ __ ] testing
the gun show loophole here you go i was
told that i could go to a gun show and
there would be no background check
so there would need to be a background
check that's a problem
i was told by the president that i could
go
here believe him that's a felony in 20
years and
i'm not gonna mess with him
no real quick sorry i'm in a hurry
can i get a gun here without a
background check son of a [ __ ]
so here that's just wrap it up and go
right
with the new i don't need a background
check correct what do you mean
i can just package this up and take it
right okay what is this
this is a nick's background check oh
what kind
what is this this is you can't buy a gun
anywhere in the state unless you fill
out
paperwork i thought at gun shows you
didn't have to do a background check oh
no no no no
well what about just like the they can
you just do it like the gun show
loophole
where people don't have to do the
background checks it's common practice
so there's no way for me to get this out
of here without a background check
there's no way to get it out of here
without a background check
yeah by the way we're back uh except
dave landau is not look he had to go pee
the urination guy has a prosthetic size
of a handball
i'm legitimately wearing ball that's a
niche uh well actually handball is
different in canada
oh we play it with a net it's kind of
like walking water polo
i still i still am very vexed as to why
we've allowed them to remain a country
yeah i don't know yeah it should be the
people talking about puerto rico
being 50 first state just canada it
wouldn't be which province
all of it turned into one state the
whole thing you speak
english now by the way um and we have we
have these uh uh
next two clips married right so anyway
the gunshow loophole it's not a thing
now i will tell you this
what i think people are referring to is
there are a lot of people uh outside of
gun shows
uh with firearms in their trunks because
they they see all the people
who went to the gun show to try and get
a firearm without a background check and
they realized like oh
skunked again and say go hey you want a
gun and they sell it on the back of a a
back of a car you know an old metro geo
right and um i don't know that i call
that a loophole
so much as criminal activity
illegal yeah but you know what 200 200
sticker and you know make sure you go on
a federal registry so yeah hey let's
you know what common ground
here's another one that he claims this
is just so perfect because
uh see if you can spot where i'm going
he claims that we need to be able to
sue firearm manufacturers oh they're the
only ones who have
just listened to his claim and we should
also eliminate gun manufacturers from
the immunity they receive from the
congress
well pieces of people don't realize the
only
industry in america a billion dollar
industry
that can't be sued has exempt from being
sued
or gun manufacturers before i get to
anything else
well that's not true in a multitude of
ways but you know who else
has complete immunity who
makers of the covid vaccine oh yeah
that's one
bring that up right there from cnbc this
is one that a lot of people don't know
can't sue them
which some people might say is an issue
to you i say
you're vaccine apprehensive so here's
the thing uh no
that's not true uh but vaccine the
makers of the vaccine cannot be sued at
all if there's any if if something comes
out let's say 10 you see those
commercials from mesothelioma stuff like
that yeah
never happened with the covet vaccines
ever it's not allowed it's not
permissible they've been given complete
immunity
with firearms this is what's interesting
about it you cannot
sue gun manufacturers or mom-and-pop
businesses specifically if someone buys
that gun and use it
uses it illegally bernie sanders
actually voted against proposal
uh like this in his state and if you go
back and watch the democratic debate
from 2016.
remember they were all crapping on him
that he only he was
he only had a d minus from the nra right
they're all like i got an
f i got an f and bernie's like no i go
to d minus but wait let me explain
and they all jumped on him and as he
said because he didn't want
mom and pop gun shops to be able to be
sued because someone used the firearm
in an irresponsible manner it would be
comparable to
ford toyota take your pick someone
cannot
sue ford or toyota if someone
deliberately runs them over with that
car
right that's what it is and by the way
it's not nearly as severe as
the covid vaccine makers they cannot be
sued
they cannot be held liable if they
inject something into your arm
that causes an adverse reaction as rare
as it may be right
i would say that's more direct yeah
absolutely and the mom-and-pop
protection is
is very helpful because there was a
shooting at a waco bar
bar didn't have anything to do with it
it was two gang members doing some stuff
motorcycle gangs yeah
the bar had to pay 20 million dollars
just to defend themselves in this suit
because they were also named because
deep pockets are always named
now put that on them didn't know that
the bar was called hell's angels
clubhouse
yeah shoot them up saloon you know i
don't know maybe choose a different name
but
that's the kind of thing that you're
talking about 20 million dollars from
mom and pop shop that did the background
check
made sure everything was fine and sold
them the gun legally why should you be
able to sue them
they didn't do anything wrong sue the
dealership of the car manufacturer that
you bought it from when you run somebody
over
fine we're going to go uh can i see
really quickly by the way what's up on
cnn here with the chaven trial
you'd say man this is getting pretty
tough um and then the muscle can start
to tire out
so we do want to try that guy looks like
he should be one of the where he can't
emphasize he looks like you should be
one of the where are they now from the
sand lot when they're grown up yeah
and uh this expert witness well he
really got into the 60s and no one ever
heard from him again
the dog was a puppet you know he was
describing no
no he's a big puppet the dog in sandlot
well yeah yeah well when it was the
monster
in the black and white yeah james earl
jones not blind
he's not no i know well now the pro i
guarantee you they would have a problem
with giving that
job to a non-disabled person they would
yeah that's true it's like why are you
taking all our jobs i didn't know that
there was
we didn't know that there was a glut of
blind men who wanted to be actors yes
we were concerned you couldn't read the
script oh yeah
you really thought you were more into
the audiobooks braille
braille script you know what a waste of
print
so here here is uh we're gonna we have
uh where we have a seven
plus one but we're not gonna do it right
now we're gonna do it here behind the
pay wall because uh or we're gonna do it
for mug club only and we'll take your
chat
because we've gone a little bit late
look let's run this down exactly and i
want to i want you to tell me what you
think
is the worst of these executive order uh
gun proposals or executive actions
they're not proposals at this point
some of them are proposals to congress
some of them are just direct executive
actions we have all the sources
available in the link
live credit dot com you can read about
them a link directly to the white house
website tomorrow we have the change my
mind with people
uh i believe it was at smu talking about
red flag laws
all of their minds were changed ironic
which sometimes was kind of the purpose
it's a little bit of a switcheroo
but let's walk through before i leave
here the world that joe biden wants he
says i don't want to ban guns no
democrats don't want to ban guns they
don't want to infringe on your rights
they just want you to not be able to
purchase a pistol if you have a
stabilizing brace if it has a magazine
capacity of 10 rounds or more which
includes
most pistols and some legislation not be
allowed to have semi-automatic handguns
which includes nearly all handguns
outside of revolvers
and rifles outside of uh lever action
rifles bolt action or pump shotguns
they want to make sure that you have to
pay a 200 tax stamp and go on a national
firearm registry at the same time they
want the people who sold you these guns
to be legally liable
if you somehow use them irresponsibly
and
just in case you may use them
irresponsibly but you haven't yet
they want the atf to be able to come in
and take away all of your firearms
without any charges convictions crimes
committed
or due process but you know what don't
believe the crazy right no one's looking
to take your second amendment rights
away
just ask the aft all right listen
youtube thank you very much
but not really you can buy this shirt at
crowdershop.com because it emulates what
i'm about to say youtube
peppa pig